And now I'd like to introduce you to our featured presenter today, Professor Bill Burnett.
So, Bill is an Adjunct Professor of Mechanical Engineering and
the executive director of the Design Program here at Stanford.
He directs undergraduate and graduate programs in design and teaches at the d.school.
He received his Bachelors of Science and
Masters of Science in Product Design at Stanford,
and he has worked in startups and fortune a hundred,
100 companies, including seven years at Apple,
designing award-winning laptops, and a number of years in the toy industry,
designing Star Wars action figures.
He holds a number of mechanical and design patents and design awards,
and in addition to his duties at Stanford,
he is on the board of Voz,
a socially responsible fashion startup and advises several other startup companies.
And now I'd like to turn it over to Bill.
Thank you very much Mona, and good morning everyone.
Um, we're gonna have a conversation this morning
about creativity both as an individual and creativity,
uh, inside your organizations.
And I always like to start with a quote from Edward de Bono.
Um, Edward de Bono was a,
a big creativity consultant and expert,
in sort of, in the 60s and 70s, he's not as,
as well known today as he was then, but,
uh, his, his, uh,
tagline that I will start with is,
"you can't dig a new hole by digging an old one deeper".
And so, often times when we find, uh,
ourselves stuck and we're looking for an innovative or creative solution,
we've gotta go looking in new places.
So, a little bit of background, you know,
I'm gonna base this all on the principles
that we teach here at Stanford called Design Thinking.
Design Thinking is a methodology that used to be called human centric design, which, uh,
employs a lot of, uh,
having different tools to make teams and individuals more creative.
A design thinking is all about unlocking the potential and
creating creative confidence in our students,
that's David Kelley, he's our senior professor,
also the founder of the d.school,
and the founder of the pretty well known,
um, worldwide innovation consulting firm called IDEO.
[NOISE] Design thinking has this, uh, you know,
sort of a set of- a set of processes and a set of mindsets.
This is our process diagram, we,
we say don't start with the problem,
uh, start with people, start with empathy,
and then redefining and ideate until you come up with a really,
really interesting problem to solve,
and then we build and we test, we build and we tests.
So, I'm mostly gonna be talking about the defining ideate,
bubbles in this webinar.
And really, I'm gonna be thinking,
tak- taking you through what we call the mindset of a designer.
Uh, you know, most of us are trained in our daily jobs
and just our lives to be sce- rational skeptical people.
That's a good thing to be in business,
to try to break problems down into simpler subsets,
and then use those, um,
analysis to try to figure our way out
of a problem or to solve our way forward in it in a,
uh, set of, uh, difficulties.
But mostly in design,
that's not useful because we're trying to create things that we've never,
we've never created before.
We're trying to create new things, right?
So, we start with curiosity.
Curiosity is the mind set that we think has the best,
um, the best energy for innovation.
Then we typically reframe the problem.
You know, Peter Drucker, the famous business, uh,
guru from Harvard is, is famous for saying,
"There's nothing quite so useless as to solve a problem really,
really well but never needed to be solved in the first place."
So, most of the time we find that folks are working kind of on their own problem,
often they're looking at something that's too small or looking at a symptom of a problem,
so reframing is important.
Radical Collaboration because the out,
answer is out in the world with the people that you are designing for, um,
mindful of process because sometimes you wanna flare and the design process,
come up with lots of ideas,
and sometimes you want to be focusing in on testing just a few things.
And a Bias to Action.
An a bias to action and curiosity will come up again and again in this talk,
uh, as we focusing in on this subject of human creativity.
So, design thinking, you know,
is this new approach or,
uh, a, a sort of a codified approach to problem solving.
It works really well on poorly bounded problems and problems where, um,
even if you solve it,
then people's needs change and then they,
they need a new solution and the solution.
It's a really good approach to a problem of finding.
In fact, I think mostly what we do in, uh,
in design is come up with a better problem to solve,
and it's a perspective on value creation.
So, that's, that's sort of the design thinking background
for everything I'm gonna be talking about.
This creativity thing, this,
this issue of human creativity, you know, creativity,
the state or quality of being creative,
what a terrible definition and I pulled this out of Webster's or something.
To define a word with the word doesn't make much sense.
[NOISE] Um, but it- it's one of those things that I think we know when we see it.
We have friends, probably all of us have friends who, who we look at and go,
wow, they're really creative,
perhaps they're artists or dancers or musicians,
and their job, their role,
in society is to create new things,
new music, new dance, new,
uh, new words on a page, they're writers.
Um, so what makes these people,
uh, different from us?
Why, why do we think these people are creative,
and sometimes we think we're not?
Well, first of all, I wanna,
I wanna point out that creativity isn't just a cognitive process,
this is rea-, it's really part of this mind, body problem.
This western Cartesian division of,
you know, the mind and, and,
and thinking is separate from the body,
and somehow those two things, um,
don't, er, don't have the same value.
Uh, what we find, uh,
when we look at the research in highly creative individuals,
is that they use both their intellectual, uh, intelligences.
Um, you know, people would call that IQ or rational and analytic intelligence,
but they are also highly emotionally intelligent.
They have access to a w- a wide variety of emotional states,
and they use those emotional states to read the situation that they're in,
so they have high emotional intelligence.
And also typically have high kinesthetic intelligence, uh,
ie they're very good at understanding, um,
their body in, in time and space, and,
and the merger of these multiple intelligences,
is one of the principal, um,
ways in which we identify people who we consider to be highly creative.
So, typically, when we're in a business situation and somebody says,
"Hey, let's go have a, let's have a brainstorm.
We need to come up with some new ideas for
the marketing strategy or the product strategy."
Well, we've been probably coming from, uh,
some kind of an analytic,
uh, point of view,
before we arrive at that meeting.
We've been to the budget meeting,
or the planning meeting, or doing some analysis on something,
and now we're being asked to do synthesis,
or else being asked to take lots and lots of inputs and
combine them in brand new ways and come up with new ideas.
In order to move from the analytic to synthetic side of your brain,
literally from pretty much the left to the right side,
I'll, I'll keep using the left-right brain model,
it's not accurate, that all the creativity is in
the right side of the brain while all the analysis is in the left,
but it's a reasonable model that we can use, you know,
to sort of describe the different types of thinking.
Um, we have a so- we have [LAUGHTER] a saying in engineering school,
all models are wrong but some models are useful and the left-right brain model,
somewhat useful in this description.
So, how do we move from the analytical to the synthetic side of our brain?
How do we move from the analysis to the creative brain?
Well, the, a bad way to do is just sit in a room and just start trying to have ideas.
You know, I always say, if you don't warm up,
you, you know, you'll pull a muscle.
If you don't warm up in this case,
you will pull a conceptual muscle.
What we do, and this is a- this is a fantastic resource for anybody who's trying to
coach their team into higher creativity, um, as, uh,
we use a lot of tools from the Improv comedy world,
from the Improv, uh, you know,
dramatic world, and, uh,
Patricia Ryan Madson, who wrote this book,
Improv wisdom, was a professor here at Stanford,
a very beloved professor of the improv,
um, classes, uh, some of the hardest classes to get into,
and some of the most delightful.
And Patricia wrote this book,
Improv Wisdom, Don't Prepare Just Show Up,
it's a great resource [LAUGHTER] including many, many,
many Improv activities and exercises that she puts together.
Um, and also, sort of, the,
the philosophy of how improvisation works.
So, when either we host or, or create a,
a brainstorming session or a creativity session of some sort, whatever,
whatever tools we're gonna use,
before we start the team up on that,
and after we've defined a pretty good idea of what,
what it is we're trying to work on, we do an Improv.
Uh.. "Sound ball" is a simple game where you just stand in
a circle and you make an ap- you make an imaginary ball with your hands,
and you throw it to someone else in the circle, making a sound.
They catch it with the same sound and then
they change the shape of the ball and they throw it to another person.
The Proverbs game, you stand in a circle and everybody says one word.
Eventually, you create a sentence and pretty soon you create a proverb.
When the, when the team decides the proverb is completed,
they put their hands together and they go, yes, yes, yes, yes.
[NOISE] Um, remember a time, when,
is the game where we just invent a story on the fly and point and shout.
Probably the simplest game th- that you can play.
You literally walk around the room pointing at things and shouting out a name,
but it can't be the name of the thing you're pointing to.
So, if I'm pointing to a laptop,
I might say, tree.
If I'm pointing to Chris,
I might say rabbit,
and if I'm pointing to this clicker,
I would say ice cream.
So, you have to- you have label something
differently than th- the name that it is normally given.
The reason we do these games by the way,
and particularly "point and shout-",
"Sound ball", they, they loosen up the brain,
they loosen up the connections that are rigidly attached
to naming things or the way in which the world works.
And by doing these games,
you kind of get your brain out of the spreadsheet mode and into that creative mode.
So, take a look at, um, Patricia's book,
and I'm gonna try to give you a resource for every one of these things that you can go,
you know, easily look up and buy on,
you know, to a book store.
Um, so, many, many more games.
Uh, look at Patricia's book and there's a number of websites,
now that aggregate Improv games.
[NOISE]
The other thing is, you know,
you can't be creative in the wrong space.
We haven't- we had expression at the d.school that space creates behavior.
Let me show you a slide and I want you to all imagine you're walking into this room.
[NOISE] And I want you to imagine what is your mental state
as soon as you enter the room.
Here's a classic room.
Most of the rooms at Stanford and in all universities,
and in all high schools,
look like this room.
A whole bunch of chairs bolted to the floor,
all facing in the same direction.
There's a little stage,
either a whiteboard or a screen.
And when you walk into this room,
you know exactly what behavior is required of you.
You will come in. You will sit down.
Some of you like to sit in the front.
Most of you like to sit in the back.
You'll open up your laptop or whatever you're gonna take notes on.
If you're a modern student,
you'll open a Facebook chat to maybe, you know, news feed.
[LAUGHTER] Because what happens is when you walk into this room,
you know that the behavior is,
[NOISE] and we call this kind of teaching sage on stage.
This again, someone's gonna get to the front of the room.
They're going to either open up a presentation or go to
a whiteboard or the chalkboard and they're gonna start talking.
And your behavior is to sit down,
shut up, and absorb information.
By the way, all the research on this kind of teaching is lecture mode teaching,
says that the retention from lecture,
uh, mode teaching is less than 20 percent.
So, we never teach this way.
When we teach design, we teach in a multipurpose room with lots of motion and movement.
But, if you're trying, I mean,
forgetting the teaching percentage,
you're trying to create an environment where the behaviors of creativity are required,
you can't be in a space like this.
One of the first things you can do when people come to the master class,
we'll talk about that a little bit later.
Uh, the innovation masters series, master class.
Um, one of the first things we come through is when you go
back to your company or you go back to your school,
blow out a conference room,
get rid of all the tables and fixed chairs,
and all that sort of formal things that establish hierarchies,
and make a space that looks more like this.
This is the, uh,
one of the bays in the d.school building.
You'll notice all the tables are on wheels.
All the chairs are mobile and lightweight.
The most of the whiteboards either roll
around or they drop down from the ceilings on rails.
Um, and that allows us to do a bunch of different things in
the space that create us stand up bias to action, you know,
physical member kinaesthetic intelligence is important,
physical activity that, um,
demands that the students are in a creative mode,
and not in a leaning back,
passive, receiving information mode.
[NOISE] So, space is critical.
And there's some really interesting research on this, and just came in a, um,
New York writer call about a couple of years back,
that the idea o- of raw space is the best.
So, Harvard did a study of 36,000 scientific paint- papers that were
ranked on the scale of innovation which were the most high- highly contributed,
most innovative, most interesting,
you know, research that was groundbreaking.
And it- and they looked at where, where physically,
where were the people who wrote those papers,
the innovators, where were they?
Two things that were interesting.
Um, there's a famous Building 20 at MIT that was just
kind of thrown up as a temporary building, uh,
during World War II when they needed extra space for researchers who were working on,
uh, war stuff, or something.
Anyway, the building just stayed and it was
kind of this familiar building and nobody liked it,
but, but team- new teams that didn't have any space got thrown there.
Turns out when you co-locate,
this is the radical collaboration part,
when you co-locate different disciplines in the same space,
and when the space is raw,
easily modified, not precious, like if you wanted to,
you could just cut a hole in the wall because you needed
extra room for your experiment to shoot laser down look down on the thing.
That's what people did in a room in Building 20.
They would literally just like,
you know, get a sign, cut a hole in the wall,
so they could run their experiment,
or they would drill something and attach it to the floor or to a post.
Because the space was easily modified,
it was a creative gym for the researchers and
of the most significant papers that came out of this 36,000 paper study,
the ones where the innovators are co-located are you radical collaboration was happening,
and they were easily modified environments.
They got the highest ranking for innovation.
And that's fairly powerful data that says space is really gonna change,
you know, the way people work.
You just can't go to that conference room that you
always go to for the contentious, you know,
product, uh, resourcing meetings because that's
a- [LAUGHTER] that conference room has just got bad juju.
So, don't go there. Creative space suggestions, do create a,
a special place where you're not allowed to do other activities like an idea room,
some people call it a war room,
some just people just call it, you know,
that creativity, uh, creativity room, creativity gym,
whatever you wanna call it, and make sure that it has an identity around creativity,
not around the other kinds of tasks.
It's really critically on us in the picture I showed you of the d.school up
in the corner there that there's a post-it notes everywhere.
That's a very visual environment.
You need to make the information you generate,
the ideas you generate,
the personas that you're investigating as you're doing your design.
You need to make those ideas visible and persistent.
The team needs to be able to come back to that room a day later,
a week later, whatever they've gone out in the field,
they've got more data, they've come back to the room.
They need to be able to see the old data because that's how they're going to make these,
uh, non-linear connections between something you did
two weeks ago and something you're doing, you know, next week.
So, make the idea as visible and make them persistent.
Remove all status c- q- clues.
Status creates hierarchy, hierarchy creates de- defeats creativity.
So, you'll notice if you ever walk into a d.school classroom,
unlike that stage on stage classroom where it's really clear where
the important person stands and it's really clear where everybody else sits.
In this little classroom, there's no visible hierarchy,
there is no front or back of the room.
There are places where there are some screens,
but they are no more special than any other place in the room.
It defeats the stage on,
the sage on stage effect,
and it makes the rooms what we call self-offering.
When everything is on wheels and everything can be hacked and nothing is precious, then,
the team has the ability to create the space they
need for the information that they're gathering and for the,
um, for the activities that they're performing.
I'm going to make the argument over and over again here that
creativity is actually just a series of behaviors.
I can't tell the difference between a creative person
and a non-creative person if they're doing the same behaviors.
In fact, just act like a creative person and you will be one.
But, the space is critical, all right, so okay.
So, it's a mind-body problem, you gotta warm up.
You gotta be in a great space,
otherwise you'll defeat yourself.
By the way, Make Space is, uh,
a book put together by two of the guys who designed the d.school,
um, Scott Doorley and Scott Witthoft.
It's a great book. Another reference for you if you're looking
for how to change either a space of your corporation, your company,
or just a space in your home where you go to do- to do
your best writing or your best drawing or your best- your best creativity.
In this ideation bubble,
there's a pretty interesting set of exercises that we do.
I wanna try to run one with you right now.
[NOISE] Um, if you can, get a piece of paper.
I just want you to put 30 circles on that piece of paper.
Um, you know, what I've got here is sort of six columns by five rows.
So, if you could just quickly draw on,
on eight and a half by 11 piece of paper, you know,
six then six then six then six then six, 30 circles.
You got a second to do that. And try to run this.
It's, uh, it can't be interactive because I can't- I
can't see you doing it and we can't talk back and forth,
but if you just,
just follow the instructions carefully,
I think you'll have an interesting experience.
Okay, let's assume you've got 30 circles or so far so done.
You can just keep writing more circles as you go.
You're gonna draw that grid of circles five by six.
And here's your instructions.
I'm going to give you three minutes to complete this task.
Turn the circles into something.
I'll give you three minutes.
And here's an example. You could turn the circles into a smiley face. All right.
Are you ready? I'm gonna play a little music here to kind of
assist you in your brainstorming and creativity activities.
When you're ready? Go. [MUSIC]
Okay. How are you doing? You're- you're.
By the way, this is a creativity exercise.
I wanna see examples and ideas I've never seen before
[NOISE] and you're running out of time.
You've got less than two minutes [NOISE]. So be quick.
[NOISE] Don't screw up.
[NOISE] Do this well.
[MUSIC]
Keep going, don't stop,
don't get stuck
[MUSIC].
Okay, now you're really running out of time,
there's less than a minute left.
Um, I need you to be [OVERLAPPING] as possible,
and make sure by the way that uh,
you come up with original ideas.
If you get more than thirty just keep going.
I had- I had students with 67 to 90 circle,
in three minutes.
[MUSIC] Okay.
you're really running out of time now.
Let's see if you can get all those circles
[inaudible].
Okay, stop.
[LAUGHTER] How did you do?
Um, a- and I saw some things come up on- on
the chat about like can we please turn off that obnoxious music?
Um, I- I'm gonna- I'm gonna debrief this with you in a second.
But let me explain a couple of things.
First of all, I set up and probably the worst possible scenario for creativity.
Um, I put you under a ridiculous time pressure.
I gave you ambiguous, um, information.
I gave you an unclear goal,
and then I just kept yelling at you that you were running out of time.
Does this sound or feel anything like a project you've been on at work?
Where somebody says we need a- we need
a great answer and then your boss is checking on you every 10 minutes.
You got one yet? You got one yet?
You got one yet? You've got one yet?
This is not the way you manage or- or promote or manage- certainly manage creativity, um,
but it's a little simulation I- I like to do
because it's kind of it- it brings up a whole bunch of
the issues around this idea of fear and getting stuck,
and how do you manage a process that's really,
really kind of an ambiguous thing.
So, first of all, did you get stuck? I bet a lot of people did.
Stuck means that you know I did soccer ball, baseball,
blah blah and then I ran out of balls,
and I'm stuck and then I- then I don't know what to do.
Um, but hopefully, somebody- you got
unstuck and you had an what we call an aha moment where you went,
oh so what if I made it- what if I made it into a flower.
Hey, that's not a- that's a different thing
and soccer balls are inside the circle, flowers are outside the circle.
Maybe- maybe you had a couple of those moments of stuck and unstuck.
Um, and that was probably because the way your brain is
organized it likes to solve problems in what psychologists call schema.
It creates a schema for a solution,
and then it just stays inside that schema and tries and tries,
and tries, and tries until it- until it runs out of ideas.
So, this notion schema,
here's a really simple example.
This guy who's running across the finish line is a guy named Roger Bannister.
He's a 25 year old medical student,
at a time when he actually was the first man to run less than a four minute mile,
on May 6 1954.
Up until that point people consider the four minute mile pretty
much an impossible barrier. No one could run it.
There were even psychologists and physiologists saying no one could run that fast,
the human body couldn't- couldn't manage it.
Roger was an English student uh,
in med school at the time.
Uh, only practiced two or three days a week unlike modern athletes [inaudible] shoes and stuff.
Um, but he was a dedicated runner and he broke the record.
Now, up until that point because the schema was this was impossible,
no one else was even close.
However, Roger was one of
those natural creatives who didn't understand that there were rules,
and he just broke the record.
After that 16 runners had done the same thing by the end of 1957.
Well over a thousand runners have achieved more than four minutes or better in fact.
In fact if you want to get on the Stanford track team you'd better be dying
close to that number you know coming out of high school.
So, it's just an example of when you know you set up an idea of how
something is and you just get stuck in that idea until somebody else breaks the record.
As soon as Roger broke the record,
it was no longer a schema that it was impossible and honestly,
lots and lots of people have done it.
I know of lots of schemas for solving 30 circles.
Let me show you a few.
I- I set you up I gave you the inside the circle schema with the smiley face,
how many people get outside the circles, flowers,
and other things you can build- we built outside the circle.
There by the way, it wasn't an ambiguous ah,
objective I just had solve the problem,
give me- turn the circles into something.
You probably made up a bunch of rules.
How many people did two circles and then realized I- there was no rule
against doing something like two circles making eyeglasses or the wheels of a bus?
If you can do two, you can do three,
you can do a millipede, a centipede,
you can even do a 30 circle pede.
But it kind of you know that's not as much fun,
um, but it's available,
it's one of the schemas that you could do.
You could assume that the circle was just the extrusion
of a solid object or it could be a hole,
in something like you're looking through the paper on the other side.
Imagine it's a porthole in a submarine and it's fishes swimming by.
Circles could be a texture. Right?
Remember I said do something with the circles.
Now, if you fell into the schema that the circle is that little piece of ah,
you know ink printed on the page by a xerox machine,
then you didn't get this schema which is simply
manipulating the thing the circles are on.
Now if any of those- if you didn't think of any of
those that means that schema wasn't actually available to you,
it never came into your consciousness.
Why? Probably because you made up a rule that said
that's not allowable and you were unconscious that you made
up the rule and you were unconscious that you had-
you had these possible ideas that they never came
to the forefront of your thinking because you had to
find a box around this problem that didn't exist.
One of my favorite solutions to this problem by the way
is I had- I was doing this with the executive team
and at some point one of the guys just got up and sat in a sort of
a meditation position on the table and I went around the room the briefing I said,
"I can't help notice that you're sitting on the table
meditating" and he was sitting on the paper of 30 circles.
And I said, "What's up?" And he said, "Well,
it occurred to me that the circle is the symbol for infinity and so that if I
simply meditated on the idea of the circle,
that I would do all of the circles."
That's it, that's an A plus answer and creativity for him.
So, I'm gonna make the argument that if you want to be more creative,
you've got to train yourself to get stuck because designers get stuck all the time.
We get stuck on stuff we've never done before.
When I was at Apple, we were doing the first laptops,
we had no idea how laptops would work.
We were the first people to put the keyboard in the back and that- and
the pointing device in the front that came out of hundreds
of prototypes again and Jon Krakauer invented it,
totally out of the blue.
But we got stuck and got stuck and got stuck and got stuck all the time.
Train yourself to get stuck because you can't- the aha,
feeling comes right after the schemas have collapsed and I've got no idea.
And then, you examine what am I
not what is- what's available to me that I'm not thinking of?
Right. So, 30 circles shows you how you get stuck,
shows you what that feels like.
Explore sometimes how to get unstuck and how that happens,
by the way when you're stuck your brain goes into fight or
flight remote-mode.That's the fear response,
when you get unstuck there's a flood of dopamine and
happy chemicals in your brain because you've solved a problem and you feel great.
Designers get hooked on that unstuck feeling.
This is a very simple exercise,
you can run with your groups to trick- you can trigger
this conceptual block that demonstrates how our brain utilizes
rules for problem solving and the more you do
this and the more you discover new solutions to this very simple problem,
the more you will lower your fear that getting stuck is a problem.
Back in the 90s bubble,
the one thing that you know,
most people do is brainstorming and most people when we observe them do quite poorly.
Here's a new model, I want you to think of yourself not
as a brainstormer when you go to a brainstorming meeting.
I want you to think of yourself as a fantastic jazz musician and here's why.
Jazz ensemble is very much like a brainstorming group.
When people get together in a jazz ensemble,
I will use the Miles Davis sextet on 'Kind of Blue',
the most popular jazz album ever still at least back in 58.
You know, fantastic players Bill Evans, Jimmy Cobb,
Paul Chambers, Cannonball Adderly,
John Coltrane, Miles Davis,
and they sit down and play a bunch of songs that played hundreds of times
before but the goal was to play them in a way they'd never played.
To make them- to make music that they had never heard, before.
In order to do that they had to be excellent at their instruments,
they had to be fantastic so that the mechanics fell
away and that they became- that they could just respond in the moment.
In a brainstorming group like a like a jazz group,
everybody takes a solo,
everybody has an idea on a poster before it goes up to the board and headlines.
And while- while someone is headlining,
the job of the group is to make that person feel special, smart, clever, creator.
Just like in a in a jazz ensemble and Miles is soloing,
the- the goal of the group is to support that solo and make it sound great.
When he's done he'll pass it to somebody else and they don't know what they're going to
play until the moment it occurs to play off of what he's done.
Now, there's a structure, there's a song at play or they- they brainstorming.
Example, there's like the problem of brainstorming about.
So, we're always coming back to that structure.
Now we're coming back to it an amazingly creative way.
To get this good brainstorm,
you got to practice and the mechanics of brainstorming well are difficult,
having not just in the moment it's difficult and
perfect mechanics do not make perfect improvisation.
There's lots of people who are great at their instrument and they can't improvise at all.
It's partly a 10,000 hour problem.
I'd say that most people who do this um,
do it so infrequently that they never actually gain any even novice,
novice skills it does much less mastery.
I think it takes you about a hundred hours of
really good brainstorming to get to a novice,
maybe a thousand to move to- from you know,
novice to expert and 10,000 from expert to mastery.
Where you can literally put yourself in this kind of thinking,
a very different kind of thinking.
Playing in that moment off of the ideas of others and
coming out of the brainstorming session with ideas you've never had before,
that were not in your mind or in your consciousness in
any form and to be able to be free to create in the moment and improvise with your mind,
your body, and your emotional intelligence,
it's the result of years of practice.
By the way, there are four steps to brainstorming.
Most people just come in, they come up with an idea, they brainstorm,
and then somebody says, "I'll take a picture and post
it on the wall and nothing ever happens."
There- there's no- there's no action ability in those kinds of brainstorms.
I always say that cell phones are where ideas go to die.
Nobody ever does anything with the picture of the- the posts it.
So you got to come up with a good problem,
you've got to warm up well,
we've talked about that.
Use the brainstorming rules to make sure you get lots
of ideas and then making it biased to action,
making the brainstorming actionable.
You have to select the right criteria.
Let me just reinforce two things.
In the brainstorming roles of course, you're deferring judgment.
Why? Because you don't want people to be afraid of being stupid.
They have to be able to say stupid things.
You have to be able to lower the fear threshold and you will model this.
If you're running a brainstorming session,
model it by saying really stupid,
crazy things to make it okay for that to be good- to be a behavior in the brainstorm.
So, you defer judgment,
you got lots of ideas,
and you encourage wild ideas.
Not because the wild ideas are the good ones,
but because it's the wild ideas that we build off of.
It's that crazy solo that gives me
a chance to come up with something I've never thought of before.
So, you have to have the wild ideas and you can steal freak you know,
you say build up the ideas of others,
just steal Mona's idea,
steal Chris' idea and use it as you know,
as your basis for your own idea.
That's how you get great output but then rather than just you know,
taking the picture and going home
and if I'm your boss and I say, "Hey, how did the brainstorm go?"
"Yeah, we had a lot of ideas."
"What happened?" "Yeah, we had a lot of ideas,
you know and Mona took a picture of the board
and we're gonna- we're gonna pass that around."
Like so what? Nothing happened.
When I ran a brainstorming session people will say- if someone says, what happened,
they'll say, you know, we had 125 ideas,
we broke them into five categories.
Three of those we think are strategically on point with- with what we're
doing in our group today and of those three we've,
we've distilled out from the crazy ideas for
prototypes that we think we want to run next week.
That's an actionable biased action brainstorm.
So the right way to think about this is when you're taking this mass of ideas: wild,
bad, crazy ideas and you're selecting them,
don't select them feasibility,
select them for potential.
And we use words like give me the most delightful ideas,
give me the most amazing ideas,
and give me the ideas that would work if we didn't care about the laws of physics,
or the economics, or the situation.
Because we want to build off of the ideas that have
the highest potential per impact not simply the ones that we know how to do.
But look, the ones we know how to do,
we had those ideas before we came into the brainstorming session.
What's the point? Pick the stuff that has high potential.
Brainstorming, if you do it well,
will transform both you and your group.
The data- the data shows that novices will first set up and follow through,
brainstorm poorly they get poor outputs per- per- poor results.
Good springs- brainstorming notes like great jazz, you have to be good enough.
I mean, if you- if I handed you a saxophone and say,
sit down with Miles Davis and you've never play saxophone before,
what's the chance that you're gonna make a contribution to that improv?
Zero. You have to be expert enough,
you've got to get to your 100 hours of good practice and if
you want to improve your overall output for brainstorming for you,
for you, your team,
for your organization make sure you warm up first for
the improv games and select ideas for potential not feasibility.
You do those two things and you will avoid
the pitfalls of 90 percent of the people one week.
When I go in and I do an innovation,
other- did in that company and I watched people brainstorm,
90 percent of the time they're doing none of those things.
But let's get to the core of this creativity thing,
I keep bringing up the fear issue.
I'm going to give you a poll, and real quickly,
we're going to pop over to a poll,
and the question is, were you more creative as a child?
Pick an, you know, any age,
eight,10 years old, when you, when you were,
re- re- remember yourself being a kid,
playing with blocks and Lego's and running around,
you could make a stick into any toy you wanted.
Tell me, were you more creative as a child than you are today?
AH, I'm going to put up the poll,
could be a couple minutes to answer that question.
So, look, we've got some good, a good response.
Okay. The response is Well,53 percent of you say,
''I think I was more creative,'' 23 percent say, ''No."
[NOISE] And 24 percent in the middle of sort of maybe.
So, half of you think they were more creative.
Another quarter of you say,
''I don't know, maybe I was, maybe I wasn't.''
A lot will depend on what your personal definition of creativity is,
but, uh, I'm going for the definition of,
''I was free to make crazy ideas happen,
I could turn any object into a toy,
my imagination had no boundaries,
because there were very few social constructs around what was allowable.''
But as we got older, and school happened,
and grownups told us not to act inappropriately,
we built up appropriate layers of social conditioning i.e.
fear, around doing things that were considered out of bounds.
And that conditioning has a huge impact on the ideas that
are actually available to our consciousness because our consciousness likes to have,
ah, acceptable ideas and likes to scheme- schematize ideas as we showed in 30 circles.
So, it's a kind of a dangerous, uh, situation.
Let's do a little deeper dive on this.
Your brain is essentially, um,
a big set of electrical circuits,
electrical and chemical circuits,
that operate on about 40 watts of energy.
Now, the laptops that are running this workshop are about 167 Watt laptops,
and, uh, I looked it up the- the Edison, you know,
the Watson computer, that IBM built,
that won the Jeopardy Challenge was 260,000 watts of energy.
So, the brain which is pretty amazing,
it can write poetry, it can be Shakespeare, it can, you know,
ca- can design rockets and fly to the moon,
is a pretty under- underpowered little processor,
that's one of the reasons why it has to chunk information down.
There's some simple things and it has to control the amount of
information that is available to you otherwise you'd go kind of crazy.
Um, but there's a notion of neural Darwinism and it says that you know,
that, ''The brains evolved to resource competition,
adaptation to process information at the lowest possible energy state,
because it's competing for energy with all the rest of the body."
Now, the brain weighs about three pounds,
that's in a average person is about two to,
to three percent of your body weight.
But it takes up 25 percent of the, uh,
energy you eat every day, if you had a 2,000 energy,
2,000 calorie is the average energy that most people consume every day,
and the brain takes up almost 500 calories to operate.
So, it's it's a huge energy sucking organ,
uh, probably couldn't take any more energy than
that if the rest of the body were to function.
So, if that's true,
and this is a scheme from Daniel Goleman wrote the book on the notion,
'Emotional Intelligence,' and Don Norman who's a psychologist and a cognitive scientist.
They've got this model for the brain that says,
well, you've got all this stuff that comes in,
[NOISE] the stimulus you've got all the stuff that goes out unconscious responses like I
just drove to work and I don't even know how I did it or I'm breathing, and I'm walking,
and I'm not processing most of that information,
and then conscious responses,
and we think that whatever we see is what creates the conscious response,
but in fact it is a lot of evidence that that's not true at all.
That what happens is stuff goes in,
and it gets sorted into the schemas,
there's that little box there,
in the big green box called pre-consciousness,
that's the thing that's predicting what's going to happen next.
And that's what gets loaded into consciousness and so the psychologists say is,
''We don't actually see what we're looking at,
we just see what we're looking for.''
We just see what our pre-conscious processor has primed us to look for.
So, there's a famous,
famous video of people passing basketballs
around and a gorilla walks through the video and nobody sees the gorilla.
Um, there's lots and lots of evidence that we're,
we're really only working inside a very small amount
of information in order for our little 40 watts processor,
to construct this reality for us.
And guess what, consciousness,
the actual moment of awareness,
this, this filtering in the world,
is only 300 milliseconds and we know this because unfortunately people who had,
you know, brain tumors or other, um, ah,
brain defects, um, we know that, um,
long term memory is where we store all of
our ideas and memories and it gets processed through sleep.
Short term memory which is six to eight minutes long, if you have watched the movie,
'Memento,' where a guy had no long term memory,
his his whole reality was eight minutes.
That's, that's where information from right now goes,
to be sort of sorted and organized.
And then, we go into this, um,
consciousness piece because we're seeing there's a-
there was a famous patient who had no short term memory,
and no long term memory, he lived in a 300 millisecond now,
that was all he had and could not form memories,
did not know who he was talking to literally.
So, this 300 millisecond now,
is being sorted into frames that are organized around our, uh,
short term, short term memory,
put in sort of some kind of a context so,
we can have conversations and then we have
the broader context because things get stored in long term memory.
So, what's actually happening rather than
this continuous experience we think we're having of reality,
is we're constructing, we're constructing a movie guys.
It's a movie that's made up from a bunch of,
of information that's been sorted through
the schematic thinking processor and organized
around what we think is going to happen,not what's actually happening.
Uh, the, a famous minimalist artist, Robert Irwin,
has a great piece over here in the Stanford museum, um,
an expression that, "Seeing is forgetting the name of the thing one sees.
Seeing, truly seeing what's in front of me,
is forgetting all the labels and
all the schemas and just being in that moment of seeing."
We rarely achieve that kind of consciousness,
and mostly we're just seeing what we think is there,
or what we want to be there.
If you are going to be a creative person,
you have to, and you have to understand,
and understand the way that reality is constructed in our brains,
and then see where the set points are for you to interrupt that reality,
to create a different movie,
because actually when you get good at this,
you can create any movie you want.
The other research on creativity is that people who are highly creative,
there's some test for this,
have these three characteristics.
They actually do perceive the world differently.
They have more visual perception,
more tactical, tactile perception,
is that that's the, um,
visual intelligence, the physical intelligence is what they have.
They're a little bit higher, and have
a high social awareness response which is the empathy response.
Doesn't mean that they're extroverts,
many creative, highly creative people are introverts.
If you if you know,
some artist friends or writer,
your friends, they're often introverts.
But they, they have an awareness of social things that are around them,
but the real critical thing is to have a low fear response to novelty.
This is that they put them in a scanner,
and they chum step that they've never seen before, and the,
the normal brain will react,
and the part of flight response will turn on,
and you'll go wow, I should run away from this scary thing or I should at least back up.
Creative people don't have that,
instead they don't they don't go,
''Oh wow, what's that?''
They go, ''Oh wow! What's that?''
That's curiosity guys and that's totally trainable.
If it turns out that this brainy search holds to be true,
when you get all models are wrong but some are useful.
If this is, this model turns out to be true,
this low fear response to novelty.
If that's the characteristic of highly creative,
naturally creative people, well that's actually a brain defect,
that's not, that's not something extra in their brain that you don't have,
you've got the same circuits and I can teach you to turn them off.
I can teach you to turn off the fear response to novelty,
when you want to,
when it's appropriate to,
in a brainstorming session or
mind mapping session or using any of the other tools that we teach people,
uh, in the master classroom in the school.
So, you can learn these,
and therefore creativity is learnable.
We're all in a box, that's just the truth.
The box is real; it's how our brains evolved.
Creativity is probably a brain deficit which is a good,
which is good news,
it's good to be used as high energy brain behavior
that turns on lots and lots of circuits in the brain,
as long as it doesn't want to do that,
you have to have to learn how to do that.
And if you can lower your fear of failure and learn to utilize
manipulation of schemas to interrupt this model of the world,
this movie of the world and build a different line,
and acc- acc- access
your improvisational and other intelligence kinesthetic emotional intelligence,
you can absolutely turn yourself in to the most creative person that that I've ever met.
But it takes a lot of practice.
One case that I just want to throw in a quick case study,
then we'll get to some questions.
Um, uh, people say well, ''Who's doing this?
Who's doing this in an industry that's doing well?"
Um, I can't think of anybody better than IBM,
IBM has been on about a four year,
almost five year process of bringing design thinking
into the company and changing the culture from Ginni Rometty,
the new C, the CEO has been there about seven years.
And a guy named Phil Gilbert who's running the design group,
and they've created what they've decided that, you know,
in a technical company like IBM what you measure is what, what matters.
So, they've created six badging systems,
you know, from and, from design thinking coach,
to design thinking leader.
And all business leaders who run a P&L in IBM in
addition to other metrics are measured on
how many people have been badged in design thinking,
i.e, can brainstorm well,
know what mind mapping is,
know how to do an ethnographic interview and
discover new ideas for products and services.
Um, the six levels they have over 90,000 people, um,
who have been badged at that design thinking practitioner level,
90,000 people in a company of 300-some thousand.
That's the fastest, most powerful
deployment of these creativity to- tools and techniques,
that I've seen anywhere, uh,
and IBM is absolutely knocking it out of the park.
There's another piece of research I wont go into from Forester that says
IBM's transformation is resulting in a 300 percent ROI,
and cutting them time to market for their most innovative products by 50 percent.
So, this is a powerful tool in industry,
but it's really all about the individual.
You, you can't be in a creative group if you're not a creative person,
you can't play in that quintet with Miles Davis,
unless you really really know you are an instrument.
So the take-away, changing yourself.
It's really it's all about changing your behaviors.
Three powerful methods: get stuck more often so you can experience how,
how you get unstuck.
What is your methodology?
Move to the Jazz Brainstorming model,
create a space that demands new behaviors.
And model of these behaviors cause if you act differently,
and you reward people in your own- in your organization differently,
you will in fact see a shift in behaviors.
And by the way, it turns out in the behavior change research,
it takes at least eight weeks before you see any results on any of these.
So, I'll leave you with,
with a famous quote from Gandhi,
'Be the change you want to see in the world'.
If you want to be more creative,
you have to make the change that makes your behavior more creative.
And if you model those behaviors for the people around you, your family,
your kids, your friends,
and the folks you work with,
then change will happen.
And now, without further ado,
we'd like to move on to the Q&A session.
So Bill, um, you know, we have a lot of questions,
um, from our panelists.
They're really widely applicable I would say, across the board.
So, um, you know, as you know,
a lot of us work in kind of multi-generational, uh, you know,
companies where you have some of the more experienced, you know,
professionals with 20-30 years of experience working with fresh college grads.
And, and in such an environment,
how do you, I guess, first of all,
use some of the tools that you talked about to loosen up some of
the older traditional professionals who would possibly scoff at, you know,
some of the Improv things that you mentioned
earlier and at the same time really encourage, you know,
the younger and ex- more inexperienced professionals to really contribute ideas and,
and kind of, you know, help with this innovation process?
Well, it take two things. One is- you know
most people want to be more- most people enjoy being more creative.
It's not, it's not a, it's not a hard thing to do.
It takes a little bit of risk because sometimes you have to,
you know, do behaviors that you aren't comfortable with.
Um, we find that if,
if you get a couple of senior managers trained on these kinds of ideas,
and then they model why this is important for the group, um,
you can kinda use the hierarchy a little bit to get people to loosen up and try things.
But once they've tried them, they,
they find that they have access to more interesting information,
interesting ideas, they're more creative themselves.
And, and, and most people enjoy the process of being more creative. So that's one thing.
I think if you get, if you get,
if you get some top-down by and from people
and they're willing to model these behaviors, other people will try it.
Um, there- there's a great story that we once had and we were running a workshop for SAP,
the, the big software company.
And the d.school was founded on the grant from one of the SAP founders,
Hasso Plattner, he's the "P" in SAP.
And Hasso was in the room with all of the executives and they were- and,
and David Kelley was trying to lead an Improv.
And it wasn't going very well because of this very reason,
it's unusual on this bunch of German executives.
So- but Hasso got up and he said, "Okay, guys come on.
Let's, let's really do this."
And he started, um,
you know, act- actively doing,
working with David Kelley on this Improv,
I think they wouldn't say more,
and because he was willing to do it,
it was exact to join him to do it.
The other thing is, you know, the,
the 20 somethings in- that the young,
the young people in your organization.
Remember, these are the s- these are the same kids that started Apple, and Google,
and Facebook, and Snapchat,
and all the companies that people look at and they say,
"Wow, they're really innovative."
You've got a gold mine with these young kids if you,
if you will treat them, you know,
not as, "Oh, you guys don't know anything,
you just do menial work.
You do, you know, you know, just do,
just do the spreadsheets for the boss kind of thing."
If you, if you engage them,
they'll actually model these behaviors very
easily and help lift the whole organization up.
Because, you know, when people come to this one and say,
"Hey, I want to be more innovative."
I go, "Who do you wanna be like?" And they- they'd say- site all these companies.
I go, guys those companies were started by 25-year olds.
And, and they didn't have half the knowledge you had,
but they weren't afraid to try something new.
Great. Well, thanks again Bill.
I think that's really helpful and, um, you know,
and really kind of emphasizes
the importance of getting leadership involved and at the same time kind of,
you know, accepting some of the realities of
these newer companies and newer menches that are out there.
So, the second question that we have also kind of relates to, you know, ah,
a modern and changing workforce is that,
in fact a lot of teens these days are remote.
Yeah.
So, how do you kind of go about, you know,
building this creative space and really building that culture if, you know,
most of your team is kind of separated all across the country or across
the world and you kind of only meet maybe once or twice together online?
Yeah. You know, um, first of all,
once or twice together online, you know,
maybe if you're doing that a week,
uh, you can probably build this culture.
Um, you know, it's, it's true, most,
most workforces now are distributed.
When I do, um, projects,
I- I still do some design projects,
you know, my designers will be here,
or like when I was at Apple, we were in Cupertino,
our manufacturing was in Asia and some of our technology was in Japan or in Europe.
Um, nothing, nothing, you know,
helps more than a face-to-face meeting.
And I made it at a point in all my design teams
that when we started a project, and these are, you know,
your long projects to design a new laptop,
that we all met at the beginning and we all met, you know,
at the manufacturing, you know,
at that point in the, in the thing.
But that's relatively expensive.
Nowadays, people are meeting on Zoom or other online platforms.
Um, they're, they're using Slack,
uh, to create what we call- you know, or,
or any kind of a chat, or,
or text-based thing, to create what we call asynchronous brainstorming.
We don't all need to be in the same room.
I can throw out an idea, um,
then people can start building on that idea in
a kind of a list format and, you know, asynchronously.
Um, and then, you know, the, the platforms,
the video platforms now are good enough to get
and we have a thousand people on this call.
Um, and we do- and if this were bidirectional,
we could all be brainstorming or jumped into smaller groups.
By the way, don't try to brainstorm with more than six or seven people.
Brainstorming with 20 people doesn't, doesn't work.
But you can, you can brainstorm asynchronously,
you can mind map,
we didn't cover that technique but we do in the master class.
Um, there's lots of, lots of techniques that you can do to generate ideas,
and then share ideas, cross-pollinate them,
even though you're remote.
Um, have a, have
a generation session in video and then break back up into your separate teams.
And wherever you are,
you can still have, uh,
ideo room or a war room for the,
for the team that's local,
and have your meetings from those rooms.
Share your, your war room in,
in Ireland with my war room in Santa Clara,
and somebody else's, you know,
idea room in Singapore.
You can create an online version of this kind of dynamic idea generation,
and you just have to be really,
really good at it cause the,
the distance puts a little of extra challenge.
Great. Yeah. And so,
we have time for one last question over
here and this is also really common across the board.
Is that, how do you kind of balance, you know,
the, the notion of creativity with some of the common constraints.
You know, anything from kind of strict regulations,
you know, products kind of, you know, uh,
related compliances, client wishes, you know,
performance, and, and sales results and that kind of stuff.
You know, how do you deal with these variables?
Sure, sure. You know, I'd,
I'd go to IBM's website to look at their Forrester Research.
The one of the things that they think volume I'm gonna do, I was designing stuff,
is it gonna take too long or it's gonna take too long to figure out what we want.
Uh, the reality is,
most of the time we design stuff that the customers don't
want [LAUGHTER] and so it isn't effective.
Uh, 70 percent of new products fail in the first three years.
Our products and services fail in the first three years.
They never return, uh,
enough money to pay for the project in the first place.
So, there's a sort of a false economy going on this as well.
The practical stuff is gotta get done and we can
do this creativity stuff on the side if you want,
but what about, you know, yes, um,
do people use design thinking in highly regulated industries like medical devices?
Absolutely. I have it,
there's a design thinking and innovation group at Stryker Medical, at Medtronic.
I know many of my students work in these organizations.
Of course regulatory issues, you know, and they,
and they work at Boeing where there's FA regulations, or medical regulations,
or other areas, uh, but people, uh,
i- it's about working more creatively and unleashing the engagement of your employees.
Look, Gallup does a survey every year,
65 percent of US employees say they're disengaged from their job.
Basically is, more than half the workforce comes to work and they don't like it.
[LAUGHTER] Um, if you're comfortable with
those- that level of engagement and you think you can just muscle your way through,
you know, the problems, good for you.
But if you wanna be in an organization that wants engaged workers,
you have to engage all of the worker,
not just the task-based stuff.
And so, when you create a culture of creativity,
it turns out everything goes faster.
People resolve problems faster,
and they work on the right problems better than their own problems.
And so, it really is a- it's a powerful way to do culture change.
And, you know, I'm thinking, and I just will point out,
if IBM with 350,000 employees in
160 or 170 different countries can create a generational,
you know, organizational change at a massive scale,
I'm sure whatever organization you are and can as well.
Great. Well, thanks again Bill.
And unfortunately we're past the hour
here so we won't have time for any additional questions.
But if you have any questions about Stanford's professional programs,
about the Innovation Masters Series, or just, you know,
content related questions, please don't hesitate to reach out to us directly,
and make sure to check your inbox for the webinars recording within the next week.
So, thank you again Bill for
this wonderful webinar and thank you all for joining us today,
and hopefully we can see many of you with us here on campus in September.
[NOISE]